("Für Elise")
- If your school had a piano chances are,
you've heard this piece, at least once.
("Für Elise")
Beethoven's "Für Elise" has become the
go-to classical piano
piece for young students.
- Do you have a favorite piece
or song to play on the piano?
- Yes. "Für Elise."
- Oh, that's your favorite?
That's your favorite one?
It's also been programmed
into music boxes,
played on wine glasses,
and used for garbage trucks in Taiwan.
It's made appearances in
movies, such as "Harry Potter",
"Django Unchained", and a
"Charlie Brown Christmas".
- It's one of the few
classical piano pieces
that most people would recognize by name.
Yet when played at serious piano recitals,
it's often met with giggles and confusion,
according to pianist, Igor Levit.
- It's one of Beethoven's
most recognizable melodies.
But the first person who published it
wrote that it was graceful,
but not exactly important.
- The piece was, of course,
written for someone named Elise,
but who was Elise?
- So why is "Für Elise" so
famous and, more importantly,
does it deserve its
popularity or is it overrated?
("Für Elise")
- Okay, well, here's the deal?
Here's the deal.
I think I'm actually in favor of the tune.
I really like the song.
- Oh no!
- I was like in seventh grade, I think.
Nas came out with a song called "I Can"
and it was like a little sample.
You know what I'm saying?
I was just like, "Oh, this is dope.
This is the old Beethoven
tune? I can learn this."
♪ I know I can ♪
♪ Be what I wanna be ♪
So I'm a fan of a song, now. I'm sorry.
I know you're.
- No, no, no.
I am being a little facetious
about how much I dislike it.
But, that being said,
I do not love it.
- Before we get into whether or not
"Für Elise" is overrated,
let's dive into the history
and mystery surrounding
Beethoven's most famous piece.
- Despite "Für Elise's" popularity today,
it wasn't published until 1867,
40 years after Beethoven's death.
The musicologist, Ludwig Nohl,
found it with the possessions
of one of Beethoven's
friends, Therese Malfatti.
But Nohl didn't think
much about the piece.
As mentioned earlier, he wrote that it was
"Not exactly important."
And it's possible that
Beethoven would have agreed.
In 1822, he considered
publishing it in a set of
easy piano pieces, but he decided not to.
- Even though the publisher
didn't think the piece was important,
the greater public disagreed.
The piece quickly grew in popularity.
It was published again
several times in 1870.
In 1900, just 33 years
after its first publication,
Tonger published "Für
Elise" in a collection
of the most popular classical
and romantic piano pieces.
Development in the recording
technology of the early 1900s
allowed the piece to be
heard by mainstream audiences
and even played in movies.
In the 1940s, at least three
movies included "Für Elise"
in their soundtracks.
In 1965, "Für Elise" aired
on A Charlie Brown Christmas.
And so, 100 years after his discovery,
"Für Elise's" rise into
popular culture was cemented.
- So how did "Für Elise" become so famous?
Part of the popularity probably comes from
the stardom of Beethoven.
He's influenced generations
of composers and artists
throughout the 1800s and 1900s
even still today, of course.
And one can get a sense
of his legendary status
as symbolized in this
Zeus-like sculpture from 1902.
- The mystery surrounding the title
also adds to the appeal of the piece.
"Für Elise" translates to "For Elise".
So who is Elise?
Scholars have been
fascinated by this question
and they've proposed
many different theories.
Is it Therese Malfatti?
She had possession of
the piece at the time
of its discovery.
In addition, Beethoven was
once wildly in love with her.
But her name isn't Elise.
Or, is it Elisabeth Rockel?
She was a close friend of Beethoven.
But then, how did Therese
gain possession of the piece?
Or was it another Elise entirely,
like the child prodigy, Elise Barensfeld.
She lived across the street
from Therese Malfatti.
These theories have appeared
in newspapers, magazines,
and even documentaries.
But the identity of
Elise remains unsolved.
And while it's unclear,
whether Elise was one of
Beethoven's love interests,
popular culture has picked up on the idea.
The comments of YouTube
recordings are full of jokes like,
"Maybe if Elise hadn't rejected him,
I would have been able to play this."
- At the time "Für Elise"
was discovered in the 1860s,
there was an increase in demand
for relatively easy piano music.
This was due to a growth
in a wealthy middle-class
and advancements in piano design
that drastically increased
piano ownership in Europe.
Pianos became smaller and more affordable,
so they were accessible to more people.
Now let's dive into the
music of "Für Elise"
to see what, specifically,
may have contributed to its popularity.
For one, the opening
sounds rather complicated.
Yet, it's still very
approachable for piano students.
("Für Elise")
- Why do you think the song
"Für Elise" is so popular?
- Because it's a little bit complicated.
Nothing can be too fun if
it's not complicated enough.
- A little bit of challenge in there.
- Yep.
- Ms. Emily, why do you decide to teach
"Für Elise" to your students?
- I've been teaching piano
for about 20 years now
and I've realized that the first section
of "Für Elise" is
actually pretty achievable
to most intermediate students.
And what's interesting is, I think
that, the tune that so
many people have heard,
that the kids really feel like
now I've arrived as a piano player.
You know, I'm not playing those songs
that are just in the lesson books.
This is like a real
song by a real composer.
- Another reason why "Für
Elise" may be so popular
is because its structure is
very similar to many pop songs.
Pop songs often use a verse
chorus bridge structure.
"Für Elise" uses a similar
structure called the Rondo form.
The Rondo form typically
consists of a main theme
alternating with supporting
themes and sections.
Here is Theme A of "Für Elise."
("Für Elise")
Theme B.
And theme C.
("Für Elise")
Notice how the verse chorus bridge form
and the Rondo form are nearly identical.
The overall effect is that
the A theme is repeated
enough times that the
listener can recall the tune
after listening to it once.
It's kind of catchy.
("Für Elise")
We've mapped out "Für
Elise's" rise in fame,
but does it really deserve its popularity?
Let's consider what a
"Für Elise" enthusiast
and a "Für Elise" critic might
have to say about the piece.
Let's first talk about the melody.
("Für Elise")
Definitely singable, definitely
lovely and memorable.
But does it have a profound quality?
Not really. It's very
casual, it's sing songy.
I just think that it lacks
in the emotional depth
of the melody itself
combined with the harmony.
("Für Elise")
And it doesn't hold this tension
that I think a lot of great melodies do.
For example, Beethoven's second movement
from his Pathétique Sonata.
("Pathétique Sonata")
There's so much tension there.
It's very delicate
because each chord change
makes you hold your breath.
And I feel
("Für Elise")
I feel like I can breathe very
easily during "Für Elise."
I do think it's catchier
than many of his other
bagatelles but it's hard to say
that catchiness can be a
merit onto itself because
think of nursery rhymes,
for example, they're great.
Of course they're
memorable. They're catchy.
But is Humpty Dumpty the
most profound thing ever?
- Popular doesn't mean it's good, but
I think it is popular
because there are some merits
in these things like
his repetition, I think.
So, yes, it is miniature
and seems kind of like
there's no finality to it.
But, I think that's a feature
and not a bug as they say,
of this piece.
It's also great because
it repeats forever.
It's like background
music for a video game,
something, you can almost,
you would maybe get tired of it.
But I think most people,
they could hear that on
repeat for a long time
and it kind of just
settles in that background
and it gives us sort of comfort to it.
- You're almost changing
my mind about "Für Elise."
But I would add one thing.
I think the melody is not
quite as melancholic nor tragic
nor as longing as people
give it credit for.
- I think one of the most
beautiful things actually is
in the main theme when
he goes to C major right?
You...
("Für Elise")
Sorry, I'm skipping a lot of notes.
And then.
("Für Elise")
You're back.
He always tries to go
to C major, brighter.
We know when Beethoven
writes C major, it's like
(intense C Major music)
Right, very heroic, bright kind of thing.
And he tries to go there but,
he just sequences back down into A minor.
I think there's something
beautiful about that.
- The last question that I
really wanted to ask you is that
if you had a student beginner
to intermediate level that
was looking to learn a new piece,
would you and have you ever assigned
"Für Elise" before it was requested?
- I have not assigned "Für
Elise" before it was requested.
I could definitely see
myself assigning it,
depending on the student, but
no, I have not assigned it.
Ever.
- Josef just cut that
we that's all we need.
We can clip that.
That's all that matters and we can use it.
Just kidding.
- Since "Für Elise" isn't as important
as some of Beethoven's other works,
it seems strange that
it became so popular.
But, this is a common trend in music.
For example, Johann Pachelbel
helped develop the "Fugue"
and the "Chorale Prelude"
during the Baroque period.
Yet, several hundred
years after his death,
Pachelbel's Canon became
his most popular work.
The piece itself is not
that musically complex.
It includes a cello line that
repeats the same eight notes
for five minutes straight.
("Pachelbel's Canon")
- Today. You can hear
"Für Elise" in almost
every part of the globe, from
ice cream trucks to TV shows.
It's even gone commercial
and featured in many advertisements.
("Für Elise")
♪ And not give any ♪
♪ To my dumb brother ♪
♪ Can't offer mine oh mine ♪
- "Für Elise" continues to
inspire musicians today.
The legend Ennio Morricone
remixed "Für Elise" into
a Western score that opens
the film Inglorious Bastards.
Listen for how the music
communicates tension
by contrasting "Für
Elise's" simple melody line
with a dramatic guitar part.
("Für Elise" remix)
You can see how today's artists
use the familiarity of "Für Elise"
to communicate complex emotions and ideas.
This leads us to our friend, Andre Sims,
who composed his own
rendition of "Für Elise"
and mixed it with his jazzy style
to create something
completely new and surprising.
- Can you explain why
you chose "Für Elise"
to make an arrangement out of it,
what attracted you to it,
and what the process was like?
- As a teacher, I was like, okay, well,
I hear this song so much.
Even when I heard other teachers
teaching from other rooms, for example,
"Für Elise" was playing.
It was just becoming
externally exhausting to hear.
I did this in a live show at a jazz show
and it was on the wing.
We didn't practice it.
After the show, it was like,
everybody's giving me a standing ovation.
All the jazz songs we did that night,
it was like, great, great.
But that one song people
was asking me like over
and over again after the show,
"Hey, where could we hear that at?
Like where this at? Is this on iTunes?
I'm like, no, it's just
the way that I can cope with my students.
(laughing)
Can you guys hear this good?
- Yeah, I can hear it.
- I'm gonna play it the way I started off
like I did in the show.
So it was like.
("Für Elise")
("Für Elise" remix)
- So by now you hopefully
have a better idea of
why "Für Elise" has become
one of the most famous
classical pieces in the world.
When it comes to whether
or not it's overrated,
well, that depends on who you ask.
For some, it's way too overplayed.
But to others, it's their
favorite piece to perform.
What's more important is
that "Für Elise" has somehow
now become a permanent
part of our culture.
("Für Elise" remix)
- Oh. Awesome.
Awesome. Awesome.
Amazing, amazing, amazing.
(clapping)
- Have you ever wondered what
makes words, well, words?
Otherwords, PBS's newest show
on language and linguistics,
has you covered.
- From determining the origins of language
to whether or not computers
can actually talk,
otherwords dives into
languages around the world
to uncover the fascinating, unexpected,
and sometimes weird stories
behind the human trait
we all take for granted.
- Check it out on Storied and
be sure to let them know
that Sound Field sent you.
- And a huge shout out to The Cliburn,
whose mission is to advance
classical piano music
throughout the world, for
partnering with us on this video.
(soothing music)